[Musica]
ma tutti benvenuti salita story sonorità
evitare stato di rhode ridavano ciao
anno cagnolino cucciolo che si chiama
berlino berlino lino ora che è stato con
questo coso dell'uovo di pasqua vuole
prenderlo e giocarci berlino no fatti
vedere
rieccolo è impazzito quello che sto
tornando fino allora pratica 20 lui come
farli si ruba le cose che sta che non
sono suoi giocattoli e poi se le porta
nella sua cuccia per rosicchiare quindi
noi dobbiamo poter prestare attenderla
sale niente in giro ecco il super
attento pratica oggi ti facciamo uno
scherzo che ci avete consigliato anche
collina
in pratica farò finta di morire quindi
cadrò terra
non lo so spero di no parli vale ma mi
butterò a terra e farò finta che sono
morta e vediamo quale sarà la sua
reazione se volete crimine già nei
commenti secondo voi come reagirà
alberghino alla mia morte sarà triste
non farà niente se ne andrà cercherà di
mangiarvi non gliene fregherà niente o
salterà dalla felicità facevo i miei
commenti secondo voi come ragazzina
secondo me continuare a giocare col suo
letto ecco che allora aspettiamo che si
calmi un pochino
così si renderà conto che io sto morendo
tra virgolette se no adesso che mi sono
agitato penso che non te ne andare bene
anche da tempo che proviamo farlo
calmare gli do qualche premio vediamo se
riesco a farlo stare seduto lì lo
abbiamo insegnato un po tributo seduto
seduto bordo la crocchette venduto
seduto seduto berlino carettoni gente ma
non troppo
esatto guardate seduto con la sua coda
lunga luca ruch e torna fatto il suo
tiro non te ne frega niente delle
crocchette seduto e gelli che lo guarda
aspetto le crocchette
[Musica]
come quasi sconosciuta
il proprio bravo è seduto ha scoperto le
crocchette sono tutto il cast a murdoch
tutte quelle col capelli è caduto tenuto
seduto berlino
[Musica]
l'inizio a mettermi in posizione per
morire france offro però dito le ultime
crocchette seduto se tutto bravo
c'è un morto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
per una prima cosa che ha fatto hanno
sarti le mani per le crocchette non
riuscivo a smettere di vivere perché mi
sono beccato la forza aiutando e poi un
tributo che questo qua davanti alla mia
forza di pista ma noi il cibo a
trattenermi dal ridere allora non sono
sicura se ci sia cascato perché però
mentre non riuscivo a smettere di ridere
mi facevo troppo ridere il nostro che
mille caste la faccio vivace per
solletico e poi anche falchi mister
fissando creati da vicino per vedere
davvero qualcosa non lo so ma è stato
bellissimo perché io pensavo che magari
contiene fregasse niente e se ne andasse
o andato a cercare il giochino non lo so
invece stato carinissimo perché è stato
vicino come tutto il tempo si anche
addormentato
aspettando che mi svegliassi o insomma
aspettando che stesse bene cosa
credevano che imbocca grandi che ai
soggetti di livello che il progetto
facci vedere il suo bel sorriso dai
torrini succede tutto il bel sorriso che
quegli occhioni questo nicchia se quando
gli parli baracchini non lo faccio molti
bellissimo to sta crescendo
velocissimamente adesso a quasi quattro
mesi e dice a lungo lungo lume quindi
diventerà un cagnolone grande tran di
lui vero comunque mi sono divertita
troppo bensì uno dei più divertenti che
ho mai fatto
non riuscivo a smettere di ridere
davvero difficile anche perché sapevo
che non potevo ridere se non li se ne
accorgeva e quindi mi veniva da ridere
ancora quasi si sta bene se volete
vedere anche la reazione di merlino
abitale che muore il suo canale nel
canale digitale vediamo se reagirà
diversi maniera differente dove si
dispera di più perché sa che io gli do
da mangiare di più da mangiare chiudeva
il contento per vedere se vuole più bene
a me forte sapere nei commenti che altri
video reazioni challenge o cose
scherzi che volete che facciamo a
merlino ovviamente
semplici perché non vogliamo commentare
questo cucciolo quel ritmo che vorresti
emesso giorni ne vediamo subito il gioco
cosa che sfogliarlo guardando è un
furbacchione
ecco quel gioco sono caduti pupazzi
vicino ve l'ho detto non possiamo
lasciare niente per terra perché se no
lui va e morte tutto
e questi sono uniti ora sta divertendo
pratica ed e noi ne abbiamo comprato un
po di giovani li abbiamo comprato dei
finti li abbiamo comprato concluso ma
bei giochi di essere preferisce sempre
quelle più semplici
lui preferisce questo che è un
contenitore più fredde ma in possesso di
risvegliato quindi fateci sapere nei
commenti che altri video volete che
passavamo challenge o video con berlino
consigliate se di tutti quelli che si
piacciono di più vi lascerò un cuoricino
e andremo a farli armi la società 4
cappelline su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video
le case di cura che preferite
[Musica]